dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Shana if I hear a
couple episodes ago we finally set sail
in the wonderful world of hair
simulations and today we shall continue
our journey in this domain but this time
we're going to talk about hair modelling
so first what is the difference between
hair simulation and modeling well
simulation is about trying to compute
the physical forces that act on hair
strands thereby showing to the user how
they would move about in reality
modeling however is about obtaining
geometry information from a photograph
this geometry information we can use in
our movies and computer games we can
also run simulations on them and see how
they look on a digital character just
think about it the input is one
photograph in the output is a digital 3d
model this sounds like a remarkably
difficult problem typically something
that a human would do quite well at but
it would be too labor-intensive to do so
for a large number of hairstyles
therefore as usual neural networks enter
the fray by looking at the photograph in
trying to estimate the densities and
distributions of the hair strands the
predicted results are then matched with
the hairstyles found in public data
repositories and the closest match is
presented to the user you can see some
possible distribution classes here not
only that but the method is fully
automatic which means that unlike most
previous works it doesn't need any
guidance from the user to accomplish
this task as a result the authors
created an enormous dataset with 50,000
photographs and their reconstructions
that they made freely available for
everyone to use the output results are
so spectacular it's almost as if we were
seeing magic unfold before our eyes the
fact that we have so many hairstyles in
this dataset also opens up the
possibility of editing which is always
quite a treat for artists working in the
industry the main limitation is a poorer
reconstruction of regions that are not
visible in the input photograph but I
think that goes without saying
it is slightly ameliorated by the fact
that the public repositories contain
hairstyles that makes sense so we can
expect results of reasonable quality
even for the regions we haven't seen in
the input photograph as always please
let me know below in the comment section
whether you have found everything
understandable in this episode was it
easy to digest was there something that
was not easy to follow your feedback as
always is greatly appreciated
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time